c'est le tout nouveau directeur général
du comité martiniquais du tourisme qui
nous annonce cette nouvelle qui pourrait
être synonyme de plus de touristes
canadiens sur nos plages en 2020 pendant
la roue de saison de novembre à avril
2020 il y aura cinq vols directs par
semaine entre le canada et la martinique
trois vols d'air canada 2d à transat au
total ce sont plus de 11 mille sièges
supplémentaires qui seront rajoutées
pour cette haute saison sur certaines
périodes certaines dates
ils ont changé donc les modèles des
avions ils ont mis des avions gros
porteurs
donc avec une plus grosse capacité ce
qui fait que nous augmentons donc le
nombre de sièges en globale sur toute la
saison touristique et a créé nada et un
transat ont donc occupé les sièges
laissés libres par le départ de nos
origines airlines mais en revanche le
trafic entre montréal et fort de france
ne cesse de croître entre 2015 et 2019
le nombre de places a augmenté de près
de 35000 30 4441 siège depuis 105 ans et
le marché canadien pourrait s'ouvrir
davantage encore avec peut-être dans
quelques mois un vol direct entre
toronto et fort de france